hey this is presh talwalkar
find the total area of the regions
shaded in blue
the figure is constructed as follows
there are three circles of radius two
that are pairwise tangent
a large circle is circumscribed about
these three circles
we want the region that's contained by
the large circle
excluding the region of the three small
circles and the area that's in between
the three small circles we also want to
add back in
the three circular sectors that are
formed between the three centers of the
small circles
i thank aditya for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
to get started we will recall a
principle if two circles are tangent
their centers and the tangent point are
collinear
if we have circles a and b that are
tangent at a point t
then draw the tangent line through the
point t
a t will be perpendicular to the tangent
line and bt will also be perpendicular
to the tangent line therefore atb will
be a straight line segment
this is true for both externally and
internally tangent circles
now let's solve the problem
we'll break down the total area of the
regions shaded in blue as follows
it will be equal to the area bound by
the large circle subtracting out the
areas of the three small circles
then we subtract out the region that's
in between the three small circles and
then we add back in the areas of the
three circular sectors
we can further break down the area in
between the three small circles this
will be equal to the area of the
equilateral triangle form between the
three small circle centers and then we
subtract out the areas of the three
circular sectors
so let's calculate this first area
this will be equal to the area of the
large circle minus the areas of the
three small circles
let's suppose we knew the radius of the
large circle is equal to r
then its area would be equal to pi r
squared
we know the radius of each of the small
circles is equal to two
so we want to subtract out 3 multiplied
by pi multiplied by 2 squared
this simplifies to be 12 pi
so we have pi r squared minus 12 pi
but what's the radius of the large
circle
let's zoom in
consider the centers of the circles
and connect the centers of the small
circles
since the lower left circle is tangent
to the large circle
we can construct a line between the
centers of the circles and the tangent
point
we can then drop a perpendicular from
the center of the large circle
to one of the sides of the equilateral
triangle
this will be a right angle
and this will construct a 30 60 90 right
triangle
we know that the radius of the small
circle is equal to 2
which means that the other leg will be
equal to 2 divided by the square root of
three this means the hypotenuse of this
triangle is twice that which is four
divided by the square root of three
then the radius of the small circle is
equal to two which means the radius of
the large circle is two plus 4 divided
by the square root of 3.
so we solve for the radius of the large
circle
we simply need to square it and then
simplify
it results in the following expression
so we can substitute this back in and we
know that the area will be equal to the
following
it'll be equal to pi multiplied by the
quantity 16 divided by the square root
of 3 minus 8 over 3.
so we've solved for one part of the
problem
we know this area
let's now calculate the area that's in
between the three small circles
this will be equal to the area of the
equilateral triangle formed between the
centers of the three small circles and
then we need to subtract out the three
areas of the circular sectors
so to calculate this area we have an
equilateral triangle that's formed
between the centers of the three small
circles since the radius of each small
circle is equal to two the side of the
equilateral triangle will be equal to
two plus two which is equal to four
then the area of an equilateral triangle
is equal to s squared multiplied by the
square root of three over four
we substitute in and simplify to get
that its area is equal to four times the
square root of three
we now need to calculate the total area
of the three circular sectors since each
circular sector has a central angle
equal to 60 degrees three of them
together will form a central angle of
180 degrees in other words this is
equivalent to the area of a semi-circle
with the radius equal to 2.
so this will be equal to pi r squared
divided by two
and that is equal to two pi
so the area that's in between the three
small circles is equal to four times the
square root of three minus two pi
so we've calculated the second part of
this expression
then we recall that the areas of the
three circular sectors together is equal
to two pi so we'll add that back in
so we've now figured out an expression
for the total area of the regions shaded
in blue we just need to simplify this
expression
we'll group all the terms that involve a
pi
and then we'll subtract out 4 times the
square root of 3.
there are many ways to write the answer
i'll write it in the following form
it's equal to four over three times pi
multiplied by the quantity four root
three plus one
then subtract out four times the square
root of three
and this is approximately equal to
26.281
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
[Music]